you're looking nice in them pants dogs
oh thanks man burberries can i ask you a
question when you guys pee
does it start with two streams yeah [ __ ]
i got like like a snake's top yes
because sometimes it's alarming right
and that's what we utilize into one it
unifies in one but the problem is some
of it gets on the floor because your
your pee hole gets all mashed up is that
why it's two i don't know
yeah and he's like
yep but then after you bust
after you bust a fat nut and you try and
pee after
it's just hard right angles that's right
it's strange we're trying to pee with
that morning wood yeah it's tough that's
tough it stings too yeah yeah light
burns kind of push it down burns
everybody's burning so i was told i wake
up i wake up with wood periodically and
i was told of course you're rare to be
54 and have they say it's a healthy sign
if you wake up with a boner
oh really that's that's that that's uh
yeah it means your testosterone like
it's like
you got that especially at his age i
said to my doctor i said i want to check
my testosterone one time and he said uh
okay and i said but i should be all
right because i wake up you know yeah
boner a lot of times and he goes you do
i
you don't have to check your
testosterone hey
that's not real
the [ __ ] also don't tell your doctor
boner well i had i was wearing i was
naked
i can't lose this every time i look in
your eyes and he was like dude i don't
know
oh dude i might need your help okay
you might have to bring your guns over
okay because guess what we caught on the
camera last night at 3am so i have my uh
rings like i have a security system with
cameras that's in the house they have
ring too and the ring picked up some
movement 3 am so my phone goes off and i
look the old line of the mountain oh
mountain lion
and listen is that true that's true i'll
show you the video and how disrespectful
is this he took
the biggest [ __ ] on my lawn wow just
have to [ __ ]
a mountain lion
that's crazy not a big one because you
live in a fairly
are you sure it wasn't a bobcat short
tail
not a big one though but took uh
probably but it took a mufasa size [ __ ]
on my lawn really yeah
insulting if you ask me i was gonna say
but a little different that's crazy you
had a mountain lion in your home rare
you can't leave your dogs out you can't
leave certain dogs can't have my kids
really out there but he's not i didn't
come at you at night well yeah i know my
kids aren't partying to three in the
morning did you still like i had some
people what are you talking about about
hilda my my late
yeah so my my girl hilda who is murdered
uh my my turtle
uh was murdered by a raccoon and the guy
said a guy said
you're you're this raccoon won't stop
until everything is dead oh it's the
nightstalker of raccoons yeah damn it
kills my koi it's [ __ ] on and i'm
thinking you're saying quick so he
probably won't get him they can corner
though those [ __ ] raccoons oh raccoon
grab they'll grab some fish hey but also
the people that you mailed to you don't
know what you're talking about well no
this guy they do pond they do ponds yeah
they said we'll come out yeah sure put a
net over your pond yeah i was like is
there anything lamborghini
what's the point of the pond
so that takes away the beauty of the any
other hey also [ __ ] those koi fish let's
roll the dice there well i might say
we'll try and get more koi fish i'm
going to get another trailer i'll set it
to try to step up all night
and shoot him in his wedding no no no no
here's what i'm doing i'm going to set
it set the trap okay that one will be
anything and then i'll go like this i'll
look at him and he'll be like
i'll look him in the eye and i'll say
you live or you do not live as it
pleases me
as it pleases me
and then i'll just then beat him with a
bag of soap
like full metal jackets cause it's just
like cake there's like in the face and i
just camp out at night dude we'll just
hide in the bushes until this [ __ ]
robber shows up the problem is those
[ __ ] who probably can smell us and
they know
they roll
hide the scent that's a good idea
that's a good idea all right cover your
face and poo right i'm gonna roll don't
they roll as a group i'm gonna scat baby
in the face just to catch the raccoon so
i got poop why do i have to be the one
covered in poo it's your raccoon i know
but what are you doing [ __ ] on you
okay but then i feel like human [ __ ] on
my face do you want to catch a raccoon
or not i i guess this is my plan this is
ocean's 11. i'm george clooney yeah
you're brad pitt so do i have to get
under you while you cop a squad oh god
this is so [ __ ] i feel like this
you're getting off this meet a log like
a trojan you're sure this is good for
catching raccoons dude the best so i'm
all shit-faced no pun intended
and you're hiding
and then we're
can i get in the shower now no no sir
waiting for this raccoon i gotta get
serious yeah i wonder if it is a raccoon
though i bet it is i read this it's the
only thing i can think of i tell you
what though your life is better than
mine man i have [ __ ] a mountain lion
of the mountains that's no joke tiny
little dude though not huge yeah do you
know charles bukowski is he's a writer
great writer and he talked about he
wrote a story about this guy i think he
was in jail and these dudes were [ __ ]
guys that when you were new they just
[ __ ] you fresh fish yeah and this guy
found out he was going to get [ __ ] so
he covered himself in poo that didn't
stop him and i believe that's in a
charles bukowski novel and he don't
believe this story
okay i've heard that that's what you do
and uh no inmates that you know your
[ __ ] pushed in oh jesus
oh my god would i rather get [ __ ] in
the ass and turn my [ __ ] in humans
is it just a one-time thing or am i like
the town [ __ ] wow that's a question
they're running trains wait why were
they doing this is it a spitfire i don't
feel like you're that attractive to a
bunch of men what they're just so more
than you daddy
dude i would be the [ __ ]
nicki minaj of the penitentiary yeah but
there are a lot of guys there are a lot
of twinks
oh they're more feminine no yeah like
there are dudes who are
young
these two get filled like a raspberry
doughnut yeah you you boys get filled
like a [ __ ] what would happen is
you'd have they'd you just see it you'd
be you would be you two would be a
cadbury egg you get filled with cream
whoa
yeah that was
yeah that was a lot paint the picture
yeah a lot of guys in jail say that's
not what you think a lot of times there
are a lot of dudes that are willing to
give it away there are a lot of gay men
in jail so there's a whole thing where
that's my thing though so if you're a
gay man it's imprisoned i mean granted
there's lockdowns you can't leave the
yard but as far as like sex goes isn't
it like that's your world
if you're a gay man yeah i would imagine
dude
everywhere yeah and like even straight
men are like i'm doing 10 to 20 like
might as well well there was a very
feminine
gay man in jail he was very feminine and
he came in where's the story from this
was uh i read this story and i
know i read a number of times and the
guy was testifying okay about the fact
that he was he was suing the penal
or you know the jail
because he was passed around
he was passed around for cigarettes and
they had yeah you know he was just
that is not what i expected hey that's
your worth
you're worth one pack of marble red he
was very gay so someone was hypnotized
very effeminate very rather pretty
and he came to jail with his nails
painted and his you know he just kind of
asked him for it though yeah well
i mean you put lip gloss well he was he
was a guy and the boys clearly wasn't a
stranger to probably being
being [ __ ] by men yes okay something
that he did of his own choice but i
thought you couldn't come into the
prison cell with makeup and liberty you
can't you you can't but now you take
those totally do not know when your hair
is long and silky and over one eye and
you're taking that chicken grease put
around your lips all that stuff so what
happened
a big strong rough looking cat yeah gay
man and no he was a straight man they
said they said
he was passed around he said yeah and i
said what if he didn't want to
and the guy all the guy did is he went
he just kind of chuckled
it's not even happening i know right he
just kind of there's no option and you
know so that was his that was what the
case sort of stem i guess was hung on
the fact that this guy had been traded
for a long time
against as well yes he was a gay man and
had probably still you know he has the
right to say no he probably had some fun
you know he has the right to sit around
yeah every day that's not good multiple
times
but what was he in there for
it was like pedophilia or like murder
then no no no hey bro i i don't you the
cadbury
he was released so when he got released
that's when he sued some mental trauma
did he win
i don't know i don't know i just
remember reading the fact that he had
been if i was the judge i'd go like this
yeah prison dude
is there anything else are everybody
good for today
have a good day i think he was like
probably put in jail for passing bad
checks you don't deserve to be yeah you
don't yeah trade it for cigarettes
that's simple that's nothing that's
non-violent yeah now if you're a
president file you know you can
we can have this conference pedophiles
oh dude they don't get [ __ ] they get
[ __ ] up they get killed yeah they get
killed depending yeah
but um
so that but i the guys that i've talked
to who were in jail said
you know there are a lot of dudes that
are just kind of there and willing to
and sometimes they're unable to give
addiction their
that's what i thought i thought they
were in their own block sometimes like
homies on the longest yard tracy
morgan's group yeah they have their own
[ __ ] yeah yeah
and i'm talking about
something that punch you in the face i
mean it's not like they're they're still
dudes man don't kill yourself they might
like you [ __ ] they have their type
and they have they have guys that are
not their type like any other human
being
so i wonder if anybody goes to prison
the guy has like a fake like a blood ass
and he's just like oh my god
you know like well i know in south
african jails
south african jails and there was i
watched a special on that you're a
little too independent oh yeah
you're a little person where did you
find the prisons and the lady boys for
my liking but carry on
we'll get to that later but carry on yep
and some of the guys knew that they were
going to go in there and you could see
the guy regular guy and
the dudes who were part of this they
were they had stripes
you know you're a sergeant in that gang
and they're rough this was
a leader would choose you and you would
clean his clothes and you would cook his
meals and you would have sex with him
on your back face to face
uh-huh yeah yeah see a lot of people
think it's just going to be that you're
going to be that's intimate
british man said who was interviewing
him said does this make you gay and he
said no
i'm not gay dude you're looking the man
in the eyes he's my woman and that's how
he's my woman no no sir so in south
african jails we got a little bit of a
different story
they just do it different out there yeah
that's that's the thing you could see
one of the guys who was in the holding
tank and they were watching them and the
guy was talking to him to come over here
and he was being he was that was it he
knew that's his not only did he know
he's gonna get [ __ ] up yeah he had
something in his butt
he has already had something he was
wearing a cylinder and his rump to
prepare his hair yeah see they wouldn't
try to get you you too big though oh
yeah
yeah
you're older yeah
and they want to break you yeah and then
they see your big nuts
oh they go tear you up yeah they're
gonna get trained but they love that you
guys are young and tired no you know
what i'm gonna do you know i'm gonna get
there i'm gonna say silent i'm gonna
keep to myself fold my clothes whatever
yeah someone's gonna put this beanie on
yep someone's gonna watch your
information murder right because i'm
right in there for murder and they go
you all right i'm like yeah man she's
got age you know
and then you say what go i have eight so
then nobody's gonna [ __ ] with me yeah
yeah and i don't think i don't think
you're the first person to think of that
and then they would look at you and go
you're lying and i'd say all right
they're not gonna know his medical
records
i'm sorry you don't connect
yeah i'm about to fight kill a couple oh
yeah yeah i'm gonna have to shank
somebody right in the [ __ ] universe
they pull their head off their spine
first day i'm gonna have to shank
someone in the neck yeah you oh you
gotta you gotta set the bar for yourself
i know yeah
you gotta do you gotta set the tone you
would snap them down you'd do that thing
and just and you'd break their neck yeah
you kill a couple guys with your bare
hands yeah because you're in there for
life and everybody'd be like
that guy no they would recruit me yes
someone would yeah you'd be the muscle
and then what you would do is that's not
what i wanted and then you're gonna have
to fight every day no you don't know you
don't
you get in there and you do your thing
and then you you have to kill you would
have to kill the leader you would get in
there and you'd be like hey man i'm your
guy and then you snap his head down and
then i run the joke and you can kill
somebody pretty quickly i think a
regular dude how long would it take you
for real to break somebody's neck 30
seconds about 30 seconds i'll break
yours in ten right yeah for real
because you do that thing where you get
your your hips in there and you just
break
10 seconds i got strong neck but i mean
i know what you mean don't say that it
makes me angry i should i know it makes
me angry i know it bothers me but i blow
my neck no bothers me i have that power
over you no it bothers me [ __ ] you
sometimes i wake you up all night like
god damn it you you you
inside all [ __ ] you know what's
weird when we're talking about people
look at that [ __ ] neck dog yeah i
know look at that [ __ ] apple yeah
you're not breaking my neck when i did
this that's a [ __ ] man's neck
i would be the enforcer and you would
just be sucking [ __ ] nope no no brian
they would go after you dawg no dude
dude you know who's waiting how are you
gonna say
how would you survive you know who's
trying to because the short kings
oh they're so they can't defend
themselves that's i'd stop somebody my
first eye yeah that's fine but you know
yeah he's actually pretty ruthless you
know he would
listen to me i mean i definitely have
[ __ ] up some of those boys
yeah god so my a friend of mine did a uh
a big thing in prison they were yeah
those big documentaries so they they
spent a lot of time in california state
penitentiary rough place yeah a lot of
gangs the roughest the [ __ ]
that run that that [ __ ] are not the big
strong guys the dudes who run that [ __ ]
are the people like the ms-13
the people that are willing to kill you
yeah organize and and are smart and
aren't afraid to do more time and you
don't care about well
some of them are already doing like life
because that that was the thing with my
dad he was already serving life so he
was just he just said [ __ ] bar
immediately you have to i have to i he
was like he goes i had to switch my
brain like you know because he was on
the street you know things were a little
bit more loose but like he said once he
got in you're around nothing but just
ruthless [ __ ] so he's like i
got a life sentence so why don't i just
[ __ ] what an exhaustion you're not
[ __ ] with the mexican mafia like if
you're in if you're in the if you're in
you know wherever you are like in the
california state penitentiary that's
right there are there are men that run
that who are 65 years old guys but
they're also not trying to have a war
all the time they're all they're not
trying to they're trying to like but
don't kid yourself you know how i would
shave my head and get a mexican tattoo
on the back of my neck you got to do
something i'm telling you they wouldn't
know because those dudes those dudes are
organized and they're not hearing a peep
out of you so the guys running the show
are older men yeah cat you ever think
about going to a women's prison you ever
seen them
you ever thought about it
you should be in a vietnamese game
there's a lot of [ __ ] not a ton of them
though oh there are there's a ton yeah
in california yeah yeah
right yeah orange county is huge huge
and then long beach too because a lot of
vietnamese people hang out with cambodia
i'm saying in prison though in prison uh
i don't think there's a huge population
like have you ever watched 60 days in
when the female side i feel like the
female is worse than the male they're
catty and they're [ __ ] i have no
desires to do time in a female prison
yeah i thought about it never gonna
cross your mind
why does breath
why would it cross your mind you know
what i think about with jail it's none
of that i just think about how bad the
food is that's literally all i think
that's all you're going to think about
about that [ __ ] the food you know i
think about survival stevie told me uh
like there's sound going on all the time
like three in the morning four and one
guys don't sleep he's like so the
ability your ability to sleep is just
compromise
compromised
and he goes and lights her on so you
have to adapt to him like that would
drive me [ __ ] nuts
i'd go crazy yeah it'd be awful
let's just not get in there how about
that how about pretty easy to avoid yeah
yeah let's just not
do anything to get in there yep
right
short kings
maybe
maybe brent is right though y'all be
[ __ ]
keep talking but you you would you would
scrap you would scrap i know you're a
little a lot of dudes his size in jail
who don't get so another guy spent 25
years in jail i talked to
he he loved to meet all these guys
you've talked to well i know that
through because i know people are making
movies on them
so this guy spent 25 years in state
penitentiary california state management
that was frank
and he said i said well how do you like
how do you avoid trouble he said
what happens is you're a young guy and
you're in jail
and
somebody comes over and says come join
us man come hang out and they show you
the ropes and they might tell you how to
get the best food at the commissary they
just they they bring you in and you're
hanging out with them
and what happens is a lot of times you
feel a sense of indebtedness because
you're with a group of dudes who are
brotherhood and there are also they're
also dudes who are everybody's in a bad
situation so it's not like everybody's
trying to beat you they all relate just
hanging out you're all just trying to
pass time and they're also a lot of them
are not guys they're kind of teaching
you how to do the thing so now you feel
like like anybody else you're friends
with these guys you're saying you're
friends with these guys you like them
and they like you
and if there's beef now you want to
prove that you want to do them a favor
you want to show that you're down you
want to show that you're part of this
group and that's when you you know
having copies
that's when you end up you know the
that's when you're a young person and
you want to do something for somebody
that's when you can get recruited and
shank somebody interesting fact my dad
went back to prison the second time or
whatever he said um when he went in he
didn't have to do any dirt or anything
like that because
well yeah i guess he like earned his
stride so like when [ __ ] would pop off
like he was just left as like an og
you know so that happens a lot of times
too
you know so easy man
yeah oh that's a rough line no oh insane
and you want to be in federal pen as
opposed to state pen my dad was in state
because federal pandemonium tends to be
a high quote unquote quote unquote i've
heard this from this guy's been another
[ __ ] bobby fischer spent 15 years and
in uh how do you fish with a chess
player no
making [ __ ]
my friend elon musk yes but he's
different he said he said federal higher
higher quality
different level white collar crime yeah
yeah educate everybody education yeah my
dad was like money heist and [ __ ] big
time drug king these guys aren't [ __ ]
each other no there was my dad was
telling me a story there was this uh
dude who was black and mexican and he
tried to roll with the mexicans again
yeah he tried to roll with the mexicans
in prison but they wouldn't [ __ ] with
him because he looked he looked more
black than he did in mexico and they
were like nah you got to roll with the
blacks yep
not a bad tradeoff yeah well jail's
pretty tribal and pretty pretty yeah
yeah that's the world
you can't be like you guys are racist
did you see uh it was all over the news
this morning jeff bezos taking william
shatner into space no you didn't see it
shatner's 91 90. yeah he's 90 90. he
looks pretty good he's still pretty
coherent
he speaks better than biden you know man
i thought it was gonna be easy to start
my own network but there's a lot of
things i wasn't aware of there's a lot
man there's a lot i'm good at some
things but i'm not great at everything
that's why i need fiverr fiverr connects
you to best in class freelancers with
experience in hundreds of digital
specialties and every skill imaginable
to help you with any project whatever it
is launching a podcast website shooting
commercial shooting a food truck
whatever it is they can help you out man
fiverr's global network of on-demand
freelance talent is here to help you
guys out find what you're looking for
instantly it's easy customize your
search by service deadline prize seller
reviews and more no more guessing games
you'll know exactly what you're paying
for up front no nego no negotiation
needed price is always project based not
hourly 24 7 customer service reach out
anytime anywhere we got you covered man
start your project or business whatever
you're doing find a freelancer with
specific skills you need for your next
project check out fiverr that's
f-i-v-e-r-r
dot com and receive tempest off your
first order by you using the code
fighter find all the digital services
you need in one place at
f-i-v-e-r-r dot com code fighter again
fiverr.com code fighter in 2021 mental
health is finally a thing you see a lot
of celebrities talking about it a lot of
people on the gram talking about it a
lot of people are struggling right now
man there's a lot of anxiety out there
and therapy really helps with all this
and it doesn't have to be sitting around
just talking about your feelings so what
is therapy exactly it's whatever you
want to be man you can probably talk to
someone if you feel like you're not
dealing well with stress or having
relationship issues whatever you need we
got you covered man don't be ashamed let
a real licensed professional help you
out better help is customized online
therapy that offers this stuff video
phone live sessions you can be on camera
not on camera whatever you want man it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy you can start communicating with
your therapist within 48 hours all right
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about see
if it's for you try it out because
you're your greatest asset this podcast
of fire in the kit is brought to you by
betterhelp and the final kid listeners
and viewers get tempted off their first
month at betterhelp.com fighter that's
dot com slash betterhelp.com
you know what's weird
i don't i don't get why
i mean old person in space also it's not
space you're right on you're between the
space okay so it's not no so nasa
doesn't count this as a space oh really
no
you know what i don't get why we give a
[ __ ] about this
they're not even getting a space yeah so
so you go where you go all the way up in
the air you go right right like between
that atmosphere and then yeah you can't
go past that because you'll burn to
death or something right there or you
just float off in the internal okay
i told my girl she goes while you're
watching as i go because i just want to
make sure that it doesn't blow up and
they all die because i want to witness
history
and i was i had a weird feeling that's
it that's it it takes the whole thing up
and downs around four minutes
oh wait they come right back down right
back down
that's it
and then you know shatner got an offer
from the guy bones virgin
you know what i'm talking about yeah uh
branson yeah ricky he offered from
richard branson and elon musk to do this
and he decided go with elon i'm sorry
with uh jefferson
because he said i just trust him more
that's crazy
i don't get why people are so obsessed
with this brian what was that thing i i
i don't get the appeal with it they're
not even [ __ ] going to space they're
just going really high
i know he's 90 but if he jumped out of a
plane we get the same coverage yeah he's
90. really he looks really good he's not
he looks he actually looks really good
yeah he's killing him he's definitely
not keto
yeah my parents uh were telling me like
he's got a belly instead of my parents
who are 80 now my mother's it's
anecdotal of course but my mother was
like all the friends that i have that
were always jogging and very thin
stayed in shape they're all dead oh
really the ones that were like ah [ __ ]
it i'm not gonna do much and they were
moderate but they got a bit of a they
got they all have some fat on them all
of them are still alive wow this is
really interesting she was like i'm
telling you it might be the exception
because people i know that are in shape
or death
100 but i think sometimes
measures are different this is the truck
this is the trump thing it's like you
only get a certain amount of heartbeats
yeah so if you work out your body has a
battery how stupid that is yeah i don't
know
old people tend to this sounds like
something that someone doesn't like to
work out says you know what i'm saying
that's true i agree oh they have footage
of them i mean i'm never going to stop
working out i don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody says i mean so you can say
whatever you want uncle patrick's like
84. yeah had two [ __ ] bypass heart
surgeries it was still going strange
shape yes yeah
he got oh he got video of them in there
yeah and when he landed he got super
emotional because he said like as soon
as he broke i guess he broke the
atmosphere yeah that's when he said it
just became all black all of a sudden
came all black and he could look down it
was all blue and he's like oh my god
he's definitely different
he was talking about death he's like
this is what happens when you die like
no it's not and
it
[Music]
brian what was that thing that happened
uh
in florida it was like in 87 oh where it
blew up on tv yeah i was watching this
challenger yeah the challenge the
challenger yeah yeah sorry that i asked
you i should i mean what happened on tv
was it 87
it literally
all our schools at least out that was my
generation so all our schools were
watching the live
well yeah that was 87 in the 80s yeah so
i was the challenge i think it was the
year i was born we all wat all the
schools watched it because it was a
teacher that was going up in the air and
then we all saw like it blow up we're
like what the hell is going on how many
people were on that
i don't know
something like that yeah there's there's
a statue idea hey did you see it there's
a big statue of one of the astronauts
because the astronaut was from denver
where oh at dia denver international
airport oh is it
yeah 86
okay i was born a year later three
i was in elementary but i was in
elementary school i'm not sure what it
is but i thought uh that's what was
gonna happen today for some weird reason
so i watched it i thought it was gonna
blow up and i would witness history wow
yeah well
you never know isn't it
so bezos and elon musk and branson
billionaires yeah they're show
they're so rich and bored of this earth
they're trying to get away that's right
well
that's nothing else to do you're just
bored yeah it's done a lot there's
nothing else to do it's like
i heard the it's clearly a rumor but
this this person knows this person
pretty [ __ ] well
and he's a super celebrity everybody in
here knows him he's [ __ ] so many girls
just
i mean a day like eight girls a day
multiple girls at the time eventually he
was like just he was like i don't know
where to go from here he's like i'm not
a gay man but i'm gonna
i'm so bored with these hot chicks
say that when you when you follow a
sensation to that level you you keep
having to up the ante
you have to keep chase that victory yeah
yeah keep doing that yeah that's what
they say about the serial killers by the
way oh for sure you just got to keep
upping it yep it's like what uh this
rush that they get or something
it's stuck in it it's like it's like uh
heroin addicts like they're chasing that
dragon all the time yeah you ever see
somebody who's really who does a lot of
cocaine
i'm [ __ ] you you see what it takes
like people who do a lot of blow you're
like you see that up the ante don't lay
out a [ __ ] line where you're like
your heart's gonna stop right
what comics still doing blow after
seeing what happened to kate quigley how
in what world are you still gonna do
cocaine when all this time
okay i mean
people have time it takes a lot of time
to do it yeah
stay up but i mean i don't know no it
will stay up that's why they do it i
guess or they you know it gives them
energy or helps them ease the pain
before the the
but if you look at the news like
we know like china and mexico these
cartels are fentanyl it's all fentanyl
and you're still so you're just going to
roll you there you roll the dice even
before i know it's dangerous your heart
can still stop i had a doctor say don't
if she said how old are you and i said i
was like 43. she goes okay i don't know
if you do cocaine but i'm just telling
you don't do it she was part of the
studies you're rolling the dice your
heart can stop just for whatever reason
you can just do it worth it also what's
weird is like of course it is it is
that
who's the comment who passed away fuquan
fucon oh yeah and it's also with mac
miller too and with uh some other guys
like we we can't say oh he he overdosed
no they got poisoned
they all got poison like the the
narrative should be oh they got poison
that [ __ ] is no joke yeah we gotta quit
saying oh they overdose no they got
poison yeah they they were trying to do
cocaine but it was fentanyl i think this
was tom petty died too was fentanyl
really a lot of people i think thompson
that was uh 20 was that 2014 no i could
be off i think and then there's some
people that just do straight fed and all
right i don't know i made that up i
don't know drugs so yeah yeah oh that
was 2017. accidental overdose right
you know how they say accidental
overdose he got poisoned yeah well no he
actually took that stuff yeah so he just
overdosed on that for sure i don't know
the story for sure
oxycodone
i don't know why they don't change the
narrative like mac miller was poisoned
yeah you were poisoned like if i
guarantee you with kate and fuku and
fuquan and patty if you're like hey
there's fentanyl in this they're like oh
[ __ ] no yeah like they didn't purposely
take something they were poisoned jesus
i think this
wait what was the [ __ ] that they got
michael jackson was that that was
sleeping stuff yeah oh sleeping stuff
yeah that doctor really [ __ ] him the
doctor what did he give him well he in
order to sleep which is insane dude in
order to sleep he had to take this pro
profile he had to take it every night oh
yeah he had to take that every night it
helps you go to sleep so he'd have a
doctor administrator this doctor gave
him too much
he just gave him too much and it stopped
his heart oh and this [ __ ] they said
they could have saved him if he would
have called the police right away but he
called his friend instead
so instead of saving him he called his
friend what in the world now
as a doctor dude call the police what
the [ __ ] are you doing yeah but also i
think kate did the same thing too she
called a friend first because i i think
people like how could you do that i
think
when that stuff happens you panic and
you call the person that you're most
comfortable with yeah because you want
advice
yeah and you also don't want to be
blamed for it right so they're probably
like oh [ __ ] i took a hash brownie and i
and i i didn't i called artie lange
all right i called artie i was like he
has his masters in drugs
i think i'm gonna die i can't feel
myself breathing i keep forgetting to
breathe he's like what do you say you
feel a little jumpy i go the clock is
start like yourself i swear to god the
clock stopped [ __ ] i i swear to god
rogan was just talking about this where
some guys did overdosed on uh on weed
they ate we that's what happens i i'm
not sure i was like
well it's taking an hour for the clock
to go one minute i'm [ __ ] here and i
kept pacing i couldn't figure out what
to do dude that's where my joke on my
showtime special came about is my friend
gave me uh a weed brownie and she
thought you know what i'm talking about
she thought because i'm so big and i've
never done it before because i'm so big
she gave me like the high strength and
there was like a
big you know like the brownies that you
get at like the the like ralphs or
something like that
it was a big brownie and i she goes do
you like it i'm like yeah you know i
love sweets so i ate the whole thing
and she goes she goes uh now you're
bigger so it shouldn't affect you too
much dude i don't know i was driving my
girl what the and i can my vision i'm
driving my my m6 back in the day down
down uh venice boulevard and my vision
starts going
that's right i go what and i'm like what
the [ __ ] did you give me should i go
it's an extra strength wheat brownie i'm
like oh
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] you guys
i need to get home i need i get home and
i go i have time to drop you off or go
straight to my house then uber back or
something or take a scooter or what the
[ __ ] you're gonna do i get home and i
like said time stops i thought i was
going 100 miles an hour i was going
exactly 10 miles an hour oh damn in my
head i'm like oh my god i'm moving so
fast i'm going 10 miles an hour who's
this josh josh wolfe was telling us uh
diaz his tolerance for edibles is like
insane dude
those gummy dust stars if anyone here
took him it's like a rhinoceros
tranquilizer but he can take like four
of them oh jesus christ i heard he yeah
i heard he's really good in that new uh
sopranos movie he has a big party so you
know originally he had like a very very
small part joey diaz very small part and
then like holy [ __ ] this guy's great and
then wrote him a ton into the movie
have you i'm sure you've seen the
surprise
really you look like an extra from it
you're not
i haven't seen it yet oh wow that's
surprising don't you love sopranos yeah
i just i haven't really had time to like
sit down and like watch it suppose he's
[ __ ] great well he's basically yeah i
mean he's i mean i mean
yeah oh wow i want to watch this
you know ray liotto's saying he's turned
down a bunch of like mafia and crime
movies because he's going to be labeled
as the mafia guy yeah i know but also
you're the mafia guys [ __ ] good
fellas and
good fellas finally
you you've never seen it before no what
you've been doing dude i don't know how
good is it it was amazing yes i was in
love with them that night i didn't
really i didn't realize it was a true
story as well on the uh the guy
was his room uh something hill yeah
i was about to say benny hill no it's
yeah something hill
right he had to go to witness protection
yeah yeah see will
uh tony soprano on oh he's great mad tv
oh brilliant
oh my god hilarious i mean
we gotta get sass on a fight campaign
yeah we do i already talked to him about
it he'll do it he's down we gotta get
him on i don't know he's he's he hasn't
done podcasts in so long
he just [ __ ] with me too he'll call me
i'm gonna go you still doing that karate
podcast
like please don't call her karate
podcast why are you guys talking about
karate well i can't wait for the october
30th fight company it's going to be a
good time i'm going to say who's on it
yeah we got some seating
you don't know either honey but no no we
got some surprises i heard
yeah we got we got a surprise
by the way you're welcome for your no
fun toads oh what are they at now we've
sold i guess we i i don't i'm not
selling these
it's my only it might be the only time
we ever do an nft right
but just give me the number but i think
they sold a thousand of them already so
what's that do for us i have no idea
i don't know i guess they have to sell
all of them and then but how many did
they make and then they start trading
thousands aren't they aren't they very
limited there's a lot of like there's a
lot
look i don't want to say too much
because i don't want to i don't want
people to buy toads because of me
i don't know i pull these [ __ ] toes
now they're what i'm wearing i don't
want anybody by any saying anything
well i'm saying that maybe i'm just
surprised that they said exactly what
you want them to do no i said that
listen you want to take this journey
down the toad road with us yeah and
we're in we're balls deep in toes now
yeah we need these things to sell so
come on the ride with us it's like when
i do reads for draftkings and give my
parley picks yeah dude they're [ __ ]
you know it's [ __ ] tough man it is
but you got to roll the dice yeah same
with these nft toads we know nothing
about it i think i have a better chance
of picking every card
yeah but you know what you know what
bothers me about all this what and you
just told me this now yeah there's over
a thousand of these [ __ ] totes
they're gonna be limited
not if it's the world but i would
probably
there's there's not ten thousand michael
jordan rookie cards that's why it's
worth something oh really right there's
not ten thousand pairs of these that's
why they're worthless i would say make
500 tops right do a hundred and give us
seventy of them you piece of [ __ ]
what's your friend's name what's your
[ __ ] friend mark give us
the next round of these toads or
whatever animal dude let's make a
hundred [ __ ] wild zebras nfts you
give us 70. i bought them son of
here's what i did so when i saw you made
all the apes yeah i mean when i saw he
made all that money daddy one month i
went i went i i was just like
when i saw it when i saw it on opencio i
saw it i went because i have to believe
this i have to see it i remember making
fun of him for buying it for what i
thought was crazy money that's fair
and then i see it and i see that there
are ten thousand apes okay so i go and
then he shows me crypto punks then i see
a bunch of other these nfts you can see
what they're worth so i go these people
are trading these things and there's and
so here's the other thing i'm skeptical
so i go wait just because it says it's
worth that doesn't mean you could get
somebody to buy it here's the thing
though you can see how much they trade
these things
on transactions so there is a whole
economy of people that are trading with
these so now i go like this so i go
uh
i i should have bought an a so he goes
well i'm in a group of people that are
making
no fun toads nfts and a no fun toes
cryptos made a lot and i went okay i go
i want
on buy something
so here's the thing
tell them to make uh nft zebras toads
whatever animal they're going to go with
next of us
they're maybe custom limited
you look like us i called him up and i
said hey dude oh my god because you know
about nfc's i don't i knew you knew
something about him so i go yeah hey
i go hey there these no fun toads i'm
gonna buy us some and you go all right
just buy some and let's see what happens
and then i was like but i remember i
you're the one who did an nft fighter in
the kids so i was like you're the first
guy to do a podcast that's why i called
you about it so
so i got so i i got some toads i got
some no fun toads i think i think tim
dillon knows a thing or two about nft he
hosted the nft uh he did oh yeah what's
really cool about the technology is that
it
it verifies so if you have a ticket
nobody can copy that ticket you can make
copy that's why it's special yeah it's
the technology is really good because
it's it's the only one you can't make
then it's a certificate of authenticity
how long i can make some fire on the kid
limited edition good for coffees yeah
yeah good for coffee how was our fan
base in the nft business
i don't you said a bunch of you guys
yeah like if i don't even know where to
buy them
well so you can go to no foot no
fun toads.com we tried that because i
don't know how to do that either go to
no fun no you didn't have last time we
tried that last time
now you can buy them go to no fun
toads.com i don't know maybe that i'll
call my friend maybe that's cat again
isn't it
nfts yeah yes yes
you said he's got quite a few yeah
which one do we own that [ __ ] one
with the chain on we are blue a lot more
than that i know can i have that one
yeah no you don't know so we get we you
gotta sign randomly the toads nobody can
help you with that oh
dude this might mean nothing we might
make zero money and i might have lost
some money or we'll make money i don't
know it's worth a gamble
i guess your friend mark pretty
successful guy
huh he sold that eight for like a
billion dollars oh well then yeah here's
the thing about it you can you there is
a way to manipulate the market
and that doesn't sit well with me
20 of the sales donated towards mental
health yeah sales given to creator
grants oh yeah that's true so that's
cool
kind of so that i don't know something i
don't trust about it most businesses do
that nowadays yeah
of course yeah for sure
that toad's like what's he having so how
do you buy them right now i can't tell
actually click on this what if you go to
open seas io go to go to openc
dot io
this is how hold on and then go to and
see if you can buy him there i don't
[ __ ] know how you buy him i'm gonna
call my friend this isn't it that's
where you buy them hold on no
that was not that was a cruise line dude
this is a nightmare
let's just do that first one yeah i
don't think i don't think we're it's
open c
open cio yeah there you go
um stops the journey okay
you can buy them here look at that buy
now
that's so crazy so let's go click on the
first one
how much do you buy now
35 35 for that [ __ ] how much
35 000 for that yeah
yeah but who's gonna pay for that i
would never [ __ ] buy that maybe
someone will probably buy it and maybe
it'll go up in value i want to know if
people are buying these [ __ ] things
just because it says it costs that much
money if it's worth that much that means
it's worth more right if it's worth that
much to buy it's kind of just more
rating cards
yeah but i don't believe it you don't
want that picture
that picture's better than the last one
another 35 000 lonely how much is that
that was artificial price history
yeah but would you they see how it says
make an offer um
it says make an offer
for one dollar yeah you're asking for 35
grand
i need to get to the bottom of this [ __ ]
hey b have you seen what's going on with
john group
ice i have seen let's talk about that
[ __ ] this right there get it get off
this get it get out there hold on hold
on board with it more than we do oh
there you go hold on hold on
you can buy anonymize i'll draw
it just seems fishy all right [ __ ] this
it's just too complicated yeah let's
move on it's so cool i'm out
as long as you make money that's good
give me my money for my [ __ ] toads
well
the our toes are 140 bucks they're not
twenty seven thousand dollars
how the [ __ ] is that mouse 27 i don't
know
i want out and i'll hang onto them for
now
all right
uh what are we gonna say about the groot
and stuff where are you at on it
you want me to go first okay so so let
me just start by saying this you know
what's going on with gruden uh
he left he got fired well john gruden
john gruden one of the greatest coaches
well done and and and by all intents and
purposes a great
guy in a lot of ways
i've watched him i've watched him on on
that hard knocks oh no that doesn't
matter but you wouldn't know it doesn't
matter but you know he's a piece of [ __ ]
no you don't no you don't because the
problem with that hard knocks and even
no i know that even the players came out
were like dude this isn't john green he
cusses so much and they edit everything
i know he does yeah we can't say off
hard knocks he's what i'm saying is that
no you people have a track record when
you're when you're a coach when you've
been an analyst and you're really great
that way i think you would have i don't
think you hear a lot of people saying
he's an [ __ ] now he used some
derogatory there's plenty some out of
fashion derogatory terms okay over the
past ten years for robert goodell from
from 2000 likes robert he's oh wow nfl
he's the commissioner of the the nfl oh
good president and there are a lot of
people that have a lot of bad things
about robert cadell i don't know enough
a lot of people don't like them yeah
i've heard them okay and i've heard some
derogatory words yes i think private
emails and he he probably said some
things that were homophobic
he called him the the
the thing that starts with the f that
rhymes with maggot
yeah and he also called him he called
gardell then now does now does he
deserve to be
fired he resigned
i think this is where and as dave
chappelle said in in his show the closer
and i thought it was an amazing last
night i loved it yes he said
taking a man's ability away taking the
away a man's ability to earn a living is
the same thing as killing him i have to
tell you as somebody who went through
something like this people were trying
to kill me yes that is that is pretty
close to [ __ ] death i don't care what
anybody says unless you've been through
it and people are just making [ __ ] up
about you yeah and you you may not be
able to feed your children you have to
sell your house you got to get rid of
your dog because you can't find a place
for your kid all that stuff goes on your
children go
yours your your situation with the
cancer thing is worse because john
gruden resigning he's still worth about
40 million like he said super ball coach
like he said so to cancel john gruden
he's like all right i'm over it anyway
and and i have 40 million most of us
aren't worth 40 minutes that's what i'm
saying so
it's yours is different yours they were
trying to take away your livelihood and
also there's no emails
they're trying to kill you yes literally
if they could they would have killed you
your situation is different because we
have these actual
factual emails with yours it's she says
he said yes so it's it's up for
interpretation yes which is a huge issue
yes huge issue yes withdrew depression
was this were these old you're guilty by
social media with gruden
so just let me fill in chappelle the way
that all this came out
is there the bigger story here it goes
so much further than gruden the bigger
story is they were looking into the
owner uh snyder of the washington
redskins okay now from known as the
washington football team
he is a complete dirtbag billionaire and
they've been trying to get stuff on him
for two years now the actual fbi
investigate him
human trafficking all sorts of [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] horrible [ __ ]
while investigating him through all
these emails
he's friends with all them and so
gruden's friends with him and some other
high up guys and they're all friends and
they're you know they're older so they
don't text they email like my dad emails
my dad doesn't text so if you're older
they email them the way they communicate
is via email so over you know eight
years they would email each other's
stuff and you had to you got to remember
at the time gruden was in the nfl he was
an analyst he wasn't running a team he
wasn't doing anything when these emails
came out he wasn't part of the nfl he's
doing monday at football and doing show
on espn but he wasn't an actual coach or
owned he had nothing to do with the nfl
he was just a commentator so
you know he said these things about
roger goodell
and i'm not defending him and he
probably should have been fired because
no team's really going to respect him
after that that's where they will it
they might they might because you've got
to you'll understand too
the bigger point here to me all this
what to me like no matter what he said
when you're talking about private emails
what are you saying a private email
private group text so what you me and
chris talk about or you me and mark talk
about
over let's say the years you've had the
cell phone that's our private that was
made to the public it's not those
conversations aren't for the public and
by the way by the way you and i and
everybody worth their salt especially
comics say a lot of [ __ ] we don't mean a
lot of [ __ ] we don't mean to make each
other laugh 100 percent some of it's off
color some of it's outrageous and that's
the point and it doesn't mean i should
lose my livelihood no it means i am just
saying something and therefore but it's
not much more consumed by the everyone
every single person condemning john
gruden every single let's go through
your emails and texts
every single person give us access over
the past 10 years 11 years you have all
said things that would get you fired and
if you haven't set them you've thought
them yes and so so but the biggest we
better be very careful private email now
me and eric griffin argued this
yesterday in king's thing that comes out
thursday but me and eric eric goes if
you have a conversation on the series i
agree it's private that's [ __ ] up but
once it's made public you have to own it
yeah i said that's fine you can own and
apologize for it but but but it was it's
a violation of your process but is
anyone is anyone curious because you
know he's going after goodell he's going
after stuff nobody's securing so the nfl
deals with a lot of [ __ ] and they squash
it they're the most powerful
organization in in in america they can
squash this but they decided not to
squash this and let it release
that's not curious to anybody you don't
so the new york times calls dana phone
goes hey we got this coming goodell
could easily squash that but they
decided to let it go that's not curious
anybody that's not weird or they want
gruden out maybe they want to groot him
out they want it better but now with dan
snyder have you heard anything there's
nothing no now
and the other thing is with the nfl it's
weird that they're going yeah he said
bad stuff he's out of there okay so he
said bad stuff he's out there what about
a guy that is a receiver on the uh
kansas city chiefs who we know for a
fact domestic violence punched his
pregnant girlfriend
tyree kill
but you're marking him he's on all the
commercials we're okay with that you're
fine with that what about deshawn watson
who has
27 sexual
you know i don't want to say salt
because he did the stuff the massage and
stuff like that he has 27 cases you
didn't kick him out you're okay with
that that's fine how many domestic
violence guys how many guys you have
that broke the law but you're okay with
that you're saying they're not keeping
the same energy
but you think there's a there's a
difference there's something going on
here there's something going on here
the i think they're three and two but
they're a good team because the the
knock on grun is he came into the las
vegas raiders they used to be the
oakland raiders right it's time we came
in oakland raiders he traded away all
the best players mack who went to
chicago who's not doing [ __ ] there now
uh he traded a bunch of stuff but it got
a bunch of draft picks for it and so
when you do that you down and you and
you double down on draft picks and the
best teams draft the best that's just
the way the nfl works whoever the best
teams draft the best you have to have a
good draft if you have a bad draft it
sets you back four years if you take a
quarterback in the first round and he
doesn't work out it [ __ ] your
organization by about four years it's a
four year backstep process it's terrible
but he doubled down his draft picks he's
drafted very well and so now
everyone is criticizing what the [ __ ]
you doing they weren't good for the past
three years but now they're starting to
get good and and derek carter they're
talking about maybe mvp candidate
they're starting to get good john gruden
knows his football he knows football he
knows football so so
the knock on him is that but now there's
you got to look at the overall plan of
it right but my my issue with it is okay
that stuff's terrible but at what point
the
where's the bar at
where's the bar at you know what i'm
saying but i have to say or it's like
even espn like all these uh analysts
going bad on them saying this is
ridiculous well mark mike trico uh has a
restraining order because he was uh up
he was he was uh terrorizing a woman
but but but he can talk so so for espn
so where's the bar so i would i would i
would back you know what i'm saying so i
would say
tyree kill it's like
but he's a phenomenal player but not i
mean they call him the cheetah they're
marking him he's on every commercial
we're okay with that though that's fine
right sean what stuff that's fine so so
i think what you're talking about now is
degrees when you say it's terrible i
think him referring to a guy doesn't
like with a derogatory term had nothing
to do with him being homophobic no
because he was using that word yes and
roger goodell isn't a gay man
exactly so he's not calling a gay man no
it's and he was just saying it it's like
the way we used to always use it he
comes from a generation my generation
correct where we use that word not it
doesn't mean
it was like a it was a derogatory turn
toward our straight friends about
something yes he was like calling your
friend a [ __ ] right he was not thinking
about that i understand and i've
articulated why that word is violent i
understand but he should he should he
doesn't deserve to lose everything no
doesn't mean he's homophobic terrible it
doesn't mean he's terrible as doing
something terrible to a human being
physically or whatever or you know a lot
of things that are terrible yeah
terrible is a very strong word what what
what he did was he used an off-color
word blend off color word be but
but also you got to remember someone you
use it privately but also at the time
when those emails were sent you remember
the nfl was there in jeopardy of going
through a lockdown and godel was an
advocate for it so he was upset with
goodell so it's a heightened sense
so
so
let's say and i'm not saying you sent
these texts or emails
but let's say when you were going
through your divorce or i was going
through something i emailed you when i
was emotional
does that represent brian kellen as a
human being dude
exactly
you had a heightened state dude correct
how many times have we had to calm each
other down oh yeah how many times when
we're not when the angels of our of our
lesser nature
are finding their way through now
imagine if you put that
no now if now if i blast out those
tweets that you sent me i'm not saying
you did but let's say you sent me some
pretty off-color tweets about your i'm
sorry uh text about your wife and then i
go check out this what kind of person
brian county
is like but hold on do you know what
he's going through exactly you have any
idea what he's going through yeah that
doesn't represent brian county we all
have moments and this everybody this
thing this outrage at gruden is theater
and
it's
do think the nfl should have taken the
stand and said we all say off color
things apologize
and he also wasn't that hard for people
at the time also wasn't a coach yeah he
should be coaching the nfl this goes
back to what i was saying about the mit
professor who was there to give a
[ __ ] speech on climate change he he
did a podcast where he talked about how
he didn't agree with affirmative action
and they they dis-invited him this is
horseshit behavior yeah i don't agree
with it and that's why i thought dave
chappelle's the closer the poser was so
fantastic because he's speaking his mind
they tried to cancel him
netflix and i applaud them fired people
who tried to storm their meeting and
everything else well this is it's
my my thing is you're allowed to
disagree so let's say that about let's
say the nfl has a no tolerance policy
and we know that if an email comes out
that's derogatory or bad or if you hit
your wife no matter what you're out yeah
okay we know the rules now we know the
rules but
if you're so arbitrary if it's like
arbitrary
and and you know i'm allowed i'm allowed
to disagree with a lot of gender policy
right now sure i'm allowed to disagree
with all this gender madness coming out
of colleges i don't agree with a lot of
this i don't agree that biological males
should be in female sports i disagree
with that personally yeah that doesn't
mean i should be canceled for being no
whatever you want to call transphobic
this is all for nothing
hijacking this movement
and and all of this is is is social
contagion in a bad way i don't buy it i
i am skeptical and i think it's i think
there's a lot of push back on it
i think john gruden was an easy
scapegoat to take away what's really
going on with the washington post yes
dude you're taking away because that
guy's the problem that billionaire he's
the problem yeah but you're also taking
away john gruden's job this guy like
that's a really bad thing that's a
that's a [ __ ] you know you know the
tampa bay buccaneers that he won a super
bowl it took him off the ring of fame
they pulled his name from that
outrageous insane that is [ __ ] gross
dude this is gruden yes they're so god
they're
they're
gutless now [ __ ] doesn't get in the
hall of fame they're so gutless but but
same with like the the they're
hypocrites this is a little different
but like with the ufc you see what they
do with that pena chin yeah they cut him
yeah because he has a domestic violence
but there's more information that came
out that's why he punched two females in
the same thing like that yeah
but with john allegations still
allegations but john we know for a fact
he hit his wife we not yeah we know
according to like we know it witnesses
yeah you know
yeah bloody nose bloody mouth yeah
they got pena but you're okay with john
stuff
wow so it's like we all know so it's
like they cut we understand why though
where you're okay with dan snyder's
stuff yeah so where's the bar here
but it's also like jon jones like penny
is a far cry from jon jones it's just
it's not a knockout it's unbelievable
he's not john
in that way
like i'm sorry but all of us have used
off color comments to your friends to
your friends yeah when you're talking
about somebody you don't like it doesn't
mean your whole life should be erased it
doesn't mean you're a disgrace publicly
it doesn't mean you have to be
embarrassed and it certainly doesn't
mean you lose a major job like being a
coach the thing that you guys should be
more scared about is the private emails
were leaked and that you're
how about your job yeah how do they
private email good luck everybody
because you know what you're next if you
support that you're next this is what
happens but all these these all these
analysts on espn all this stuff like in
these coaches and players going at them
hard it's like
give access give somebody access to all
your emails
the guy the guy who he's [ __ ] the
singer for the civil wars or whatever
that [ __ ] i don't know what that
[ __ ] group is and he wrote a book he
read a book on antifa about what what
[ __ ] [ __ ] antifa is and he said
and he texted and he said he put he did
a thing he said uh this is a worthy read
and the outrage they were like how dare
you criticizing tv even his own band
members and he said i'm taking some time
to reflect and he had to apologize
you're such a [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ]
yeah and by the way leaking emails and
stuff like that and then your life is
ruined uh how many how many people has
this happened
like they've never let them like speak
for himself or you'll apologize they're
hypocrites
because i think the biggest one that
screwed him over well
to the public not you know him calling
um roger goodell a [ __ ] and uh the the
f word uh-huh you know i think that's
more of a goodell private issue and
that's probably why goodell at the
release but the biggest one that got him
in all the hot water was him saying that
that that maurice uh mary's green or
smith whoever's in charge of the nflpa
he's a black man with big lips and he
said that guy's lips the size of
michelin tires so people took that
that's the thing like i'm in trouble but
but he's not saying that no he was
saying just because i said that about
yourself
nick davis yesterday was like
he was like you have mitchell entire
lips yeah he's like i don't see how this
is that's not racist i'm saying
it's big lips and by the way
i mean here
that's not that is such a [ __ ] thing
to read into you he's not you're not
making the world less racist by calling
him out on that you're not doing that
but so this is not you're this is virtue
signaling you're not making the world
better you're it doesn't make the world
less prejudiced or more equal by getting
rid of john gruden it doesn't so it just
creates resentment this is not
reasonable
they just didn't like but they didn't
like him something else was going on
here yeah like you said he goes he's
been a constant irritant to the nfl he's
fought back against efforts to make the
game safer to reduce concussions he's
old school he doesn't like how soft the
nfl is he doesn't like female referees
he doesn't like colin kaepernick taking
the knee that's his prerogative
but they want they don't like that they
want him out of there um so he was able
to but he was able to speak for himself
and apologize and yeah he apologized so
then
why is it why is it still like this tear
down like what like what more do you
want that's what people like from this
person
like if he's people he's able to own
like all that [ __ ] twitter ain't a real
place it's not it's not i don't know
these big vibrations about it they're a
bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but yeah that's just
yeah i don't know i always always think
it's wrong when someone's like coming
out like you know and owning it and
owning it and you know being able to
talk about like hey you know what that
was that was wrong with me or just any
[ __ ] like that and
you know the fact that we can't move on
from that then we have to continue to
tear these type of people down you know
it's like hey like let that like let
them grow let them grow again let them
you know
you know do do you know do the right
thing you know i mean that it takes a
lot to stand up and like own your [ __ ]
yeah and you can also say things you
don't mean sometimes yeah
we all say things we don't mean
sometimes sometimes we're joking other
times we're
really angry other times we've lost
control unfortunately
i've said i've told my mom when i was
younger that i hate her because i was
really angry at her yeah i don't hate my
mom i loved her yeah when you were a
little kid you go i hope you die you
don't mean that you you when you're in a
breakup as an adult you can say some
nasty [ __ ] crazy the person you love or
you live because you're emotional you
mean it in the moment well that i mean
i mean that's a lot of [ __ ] that i
learned in anger management and i mean
that's just yeah you don't basically you
know you know but i also think like
they're like backstory they're like how
could he face the team after that stuff
being leaked it's like oh you've never
been in a locker room these analysts i
was like
you know the type of
they call it locker room talk you don't
think those guys have heard words
you don't think the efforts thrown
around every three seconds in the locker
room
you know what's been fascinating is
watching uh hard knocks the raiders and
watching the difference between the guys
that start and the guys that make the
practice squad
first of all my god is it cutthroat and
my god is it competitive and my god my
god football like ezekiel i'm sorry
elliot yeah elliot
he was showing this guy who made the
practice squad who's a really good
player he's like you got to hesitate and
look for the hole and he showed him how
he shows you how smart ezekiel is right
you're like [ __ ] dude
i don't know what that means i don't
know what mine first james insane yeah
you're like you see holes
and you can hesitate and that that
that's so good this much
seconds yeah
between the starters and guys on the
practice squad and so let you would know
about this too because i got invested
emotionally to my boys who are now in
the practice squad yeah what is it
practice squad mean will they ever play
for the yeah it's a tough life you
usually bounce around teams is that like
being in the minor leagues no not at all
you're still in the nfl you're in the
nfl but you're just a practice squad
player so people think because you're in
the nfl you're making millions those
guys i think the average salary is
around 75k you're not getting like
normal
and so you're playing and so like i just
who was the quarterback um pretty good
quarterback but he's practice squad so
so who might be called up
it could be tough there's a few guys
make it but not really you know [ __ ] it
leave your practice what guys next year
yeah they bounce around all these it's a
tough life man you know
they can't put their roots down and you
can get picked up by another team
sometimes yeah especially they cut you
how would that work
just the team needs a quarterback and
then you can fill in maybe your second
string or third string
hopefully hopefully
but making the team it's like those
practice squad guys so let's say dallas
is playing uh the chiefs that practice
swat guy would give them looks to look
like patrick mahomes as close as he can
that's his job my girl said to me when
when the guy from the ivory coast made
the team and he gets a call
i got emotional man because i watched f
i got emotional because it's so hard
yeah and uh lifelong maybe maybe i maybe
i've maybe i kind of identify with how
hard it is to be an actor when you get a
tv show it could be the only show you
ever get in your whole life you've been
there for 20 years and and but most of
the time you all you're on the practice
squad as an actor you're just always
getting so maybe i
identify with you get a call that can
change your life and when you get a call
like that it changes your life you mean
in the nfl you're playing you're on the
team you're on the team you're on the
53-man roster yeah which doesn't mean
you're going to play by the way no
still got a lot of work to do it gives
you an idea of how special someone like
adrian peterson of those guys are how
special they are yeah how how incredible
it is when you play ten years in your
school let's talk about your computer
another guy down trouble for him his son
scrotum with a switch
and we're all fine with it we all cheer
him on and he's the life of the party
and it's all good is he playing he's got
seven eight kids yeah i don't know what
he's doing now he might be on the red
skins i don't know but we're just cool
with that
then i felt school with it yeah take a
kill and i felt school with it yeah
strange
well it's just money it's money yeah
talent what else you got can give some
current events
let's take a little break from chat with
the boys and jump right back in with the
show cause today's fight in the kit is
brought to you by athletic greens the
health and wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
simple right there's a lot of stresses
in life man or
maybe not sleeping well maybe you've got
a busy schedule maybe you can't exercise
the way you want maybe work stressful
whatever it is your diet suffering and
you're not getting those nutritional
needs that you need that's why ag-1 by
athletic greens all right it's a super
food we got you covered man one tasty
scoop of ag one contains 75 vitamins
minerals whole food source ingredients
including multivitamins multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend and they
got everything in it man it's delicious
it's tasty i put in eight ounces water
and i'm off to the races all right so
join the move of athletes
comics podcasters dads rookies whoever
you are i got you covered man because
nutrition's important make it easy with
athletic greens all right uh they're
gonna give you guys immune supporting
free one year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athletic
greens.com fighter today again all you
gotta do is visit athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give ag-1 a try this episode of
finally kid is brought to you by on it
on it supplements we got you covered man
you think he's out there you gotta stay
thick but you gotta stay healthy and
need some help with your supplements but
you don't trust any supplement trust the
trust the best on the planet we're
talking about on it whatever you need
man we got jointel krill oil shroom tech
we got creatine glutamine we got mood
and sleep enhancers we've got
performance collection healthy snacks
collection we got it all man what what
do you need some coffee check elk bars
warrior bars fat butters check check
protein powders check mct oil check
fitness gear for your thick ass what do
you want kettlebells i gotcha steel club
macy's i gotcha streaming fitness at
home on demand workouts on it in 30 what
on it six all right barbells bodyweight
durability kettlebell steel club steel
maces on it sandbags battle ropes sounds
great go to onnit.com fighter temp send
off everything on it dot com slash
fighter here we go
so demi lovato went viral recently and
she had a new show out where she is
basically a alien hunter she's going
around speaking to people who've had
experiences with
aliens and she's going to different
places
as a promotional video she did an
interview where she said she does not
like using the term aliens and she
prefers calling them extraterrestrial
because the word alien is derogatory
just across the board yeah dude could
there be a more lost human being
she is such a mess dude she's so
talented alien
yeah she's saying that the word alien is
now very derogatory because you say who
does she decided that she decided that
okay right i think she's referring to
illegal aliens that's why just keep
singing and how that is derogatory yeah
but you're saying you know
but just saying her voice is amazing
she's non-binary she didn't even know
what that meant she's i wonder why she
can't keep a man
we were singing her [ __ ] and dude shut
them up
you're talking about us
aliens out of her mind i actually but
also this makes headlines like this
she's just trying to you know
stay stay relevant and the weirdest and
then she'd come out pan or buy and just
say it's one thing after another and
then she went hard on me she went hard
on frozen yogurt said this isn't fair
i'm on a diet and i have to pass all the
tasty stuff before i get to the healthy
stuff yeah
yeah well okay
listen she's she's probably hey
hey this is nothing
i'm we're busy everybody's trying to get
to work and do their thing yeah what's
odd is what people find is like a
problem like certain people you know you
get he gets attention i i was listening
jordan peterson was talking about how
somebody said well this is a this is a
patriarchal
tyranny like the west is run by the
patriarchy and it's tyrannical and he
said well it's also it's it's run by
it's a it's a hierarchy of competence
and he said have you ever thought about
what goes into the infrastructure that
you benefit from every day just the fact
that the lights are on do you know what
it takes to keep the lights on do you
know what it takes to have fresh fruits
and vegetables
uh on the stand in the middle of the
winter do you know what it takes to have
clean water do you know what it takes to
treat all the sewage oh i take all of it
for granted we take we take it for
granted and the people that are running
that you don't know who they are they're
very very [ __ ] competent keeping your
highways clean safe making sure that the
signs making sure the planes that take
off are in the different areas and the
place and land we can just keep going
none of us know what the [ __ ] we're
talking about we paid for so when we
talk about all this surface level [ __ ]
about this not being supposed that's a
complete waste time it's like no that
you you only fired it's crazy that it
made a headline
people are crazy that that's well she
has a pr team i'm sure you know and she
pays them for it so it's like whatever
she says gets blasted out and then we're
talking about it she's got a lot of
issues and also saying that that's okay
she has all the issues name an issue she
has an issue you know what i like about
christians they go like this i pray for
her i wish i'll meet you it's very
simple i love when they do that
i love how tyson fury is like i'll pray
to soften his heart
it's such a fun thing to say i pray for
you dude that's a powerful thing right
before somebody's going to shoot you
i pray for you man for you that's so
nice
so a 24 year old
living in dubai who's originally from
london got arrested because
he was approached by police officers
that said they heard he had drugs in his
system and in dubai that's illegal so he
did a drug test it all came back
negative so they then asked can we
search your car and your apartment he
said go ahead i don't do drugs so i have
nothing to worry about
they actually found four small bottles
of cbd oil in his car along with some
loose cash
so they arrested him and after spending
a few five years after spending a few
days in prison and uh he's trying to get
a legal team together to help him he was
actually given a piece of paper told to
sign he didn't know what he was signing
it was actually a paper admitting that
he not only is doing drugs but he's
selling jesus which then uh brought his
sentence from what could have been a few
years in a prison in dubai 25.
just even prison for cbd or cbd so when
i lived in saudi arabia i was four i was
13 years old 14 years old and a 14 year
old in dahran
that year
was caught with a joint and they put her
in jail for 25 years and there's nothing
so in the middle east they don't [ __ ]
around and then my friend was selling
furniture in the middle east he was
making furniture and selling it and he
uh
some of his friends were smoking weed
and they were bringing weed in from you
get really good hashish there right and
they brought some hash in from turkey
and they were they had a party well they
got caught and my friend
left and i said why'd you leave he goes
because my friends got their head couple
of them got their heads cut off
distributing for being for being drug
distributors
they don't [ __ ] around with that stuff
they don't [ __ ] around that's such a
shame for that guy with cbd yeah so his
parents right now are working on having
the embassy actually help a mountain tea
if
they can try to get them out somehow
because there wasn't any in this system
so they were trying to get them on the
fact that he was selling ah dang that's
so tough he's going away for a little
bit though yeah well it's like i watched
a video on world star hip-hop this guy
because you know the in india they have
the cast system this guy drank water out
of a filter that was for the upper
echelon cast but he's lower cast you
know he's untouchable
there and i hate watching these videos
but sometimes i gotta see it they beat
the shot this guy with sticks yeah i
mean literally beat them in a pulp
because they drank out of the water
yeah they're supposed to go to the upper
echelon because in india the casters
the untouchables are like the worst
thing you can be and they think that if
you're an untouchable you did something
your past life and you came back as an
untouchable so you clean you have the
you do the [ __ ] work you clean toilets
that makes sense everybody by the way
before we go
demi lovato's talking about [ __ ]
aliens yeah and that guy was just trying
to get fresh water was beaten to the
inch of his life so i was saying that's
funny you keep fighting for aliens that
you don't know speaking of beating into
his life did you see the mountain lion
that
attacked the guy's dog and the guy came
running out with a machete no did he
kill him and kill the mountain lion is
there a video of it oh yeah see if you
guys see them outlining the face i did
and the mountain lion's like two feet
away yeah i feel like i need to see both
of these you tried to pounce on me like
i didn't see that dude yeah
that's a little too close for comfort oh
but himalayan was he kind of checking
things out it was a smaller mountain
lion maybe you shot them right in the
[ __ ] face i don't know where's it at
i wasn't there
look at this watch this this is the one
watch that mountain lion it's a younger
mountain lion is this going to be tough
to watch jen i don't know i've never
seen it
watch this watch this this thing just
comes out grassy that's way bigger than
the mountain and took a [ __ ] about his
dog watch this grabs his tongue the dog
went off to the mountain lion i don't
know watch this well that dog's chasing
oh there you go oh oh my god
oh [ __ ] that dog's like what in the
future just decides to kill that dog oh
he killed the dog no no watch that watch
this guy
you don't really see it
damn does he let go of the dog oh no
he's beating it it's like he's beating a
cougar it's not even running away
oh you're running away that's cool and
that mountain lions
it's got it why is the mount lane let go
because it's dead it's time well and oh
the dog's trying to fight that dog would
have been dead that dog would have been
[ __ ]
and it might still be because these guns
go for the belly where it's soft as
terrible as it sounds oh oh wow that's
terrible oh that dog's [ __ ] that
mountain lion up now that's a small
mountain lion
what was it that's what this is the
mountain lion that i saw
not only that dude
do i say [ __ ] dude
a splatter of like diarrhea you had to
pick it up
[Music]
machete what what did you say my son
goes dad poo poo little boss was out
because you go outside in the morning it
was dad poo poo i'm like what the [ __ ]
is that dude send me that video i want
to show you that
um the other guy shoots them out lying
in the face go there yeah you see that
one
what happened the guy shoot chin was sad
and hurt
i'm good man so you want to see it on
that mri
get that mri right now
you know what sucks dude so i'll just be
honest
the mri place i got approved
i called them six times yesterday left
two voicemails they never called me back
[ __ ] dude and i looked at yelp it's two
stars they said there's a the complaints
filed or whatever but i was able to call
someone today and someone answered they
said that they would schedule me for
saturday morning okay and they'll send
me a confirmation they never sent me
confirmation so i'm just gonna show up
yeah can we uh yeah just get a [ __ ]
mri yeah i'm trying bro
he's trying how much does it cost brian
15 000. how much 15 pounds i'm kidding
oh i was like
it's more like 1500 yeah that's like
1500 yeah okay okay so wait mountain
lion
because
yeah it goes this guy shoots my line in
the [ __ ] face no this is not i think
that's the guy he also heard the
you get back
i feel like you didn't give it much back
that mountain lion could jump from there
yeah
but he also acts like the mauling speaks
english which is another problem and
he's filming like with what that
mountain lion is looking to get him man
kind of but he's also like dude you got
food
no
no no
we can't see what happened yeah but
you'll see i'm right in the face
see there's another
mountain lion
pounced at me and i popped it in the
face they like falls down the mountain
like he wouldn't hunt
they're cool why do you kill like i i
would have to eat something when i see a
deer in my mouth water so i want to
shoot that no deers oh look at him
that's a good size mountain lion
stupid cat
i shot it right in the face
well you shot more in the neck though
huh yeah i got him in the face i saw
that i saw the video oh my god just a
very small hole
is there more to this just that's it you
know they're not endangered
no not anymore
yeah well in california you can't kill
them you know that yeah so if that one's
in my backyard i'd get on my ar15 one of
the four that i have and i shoot them
i'll get in trouble
well you could just change i'll say he's
going for my kid i'll just say he's
going for my kid
yeah
yeah like i shot in the [ __ ] what did he
tell you to do if it gets in your
backyard then
dude it's illegal to kill him
unless you're in danger but i'll show
you guys
i'll be like he was trying to steal my
tv
shoot him in the back
in the back
i want to see you wrestle at chimpanzee
not fun
so tim mcgraw was performing at a
concert man he's in shape yeah workout
routine
he's always been pretty in shape hasn't
he yeah but he has a workout routine on
the road he just like vlogs like i do
dude he's [ __ ] he killed it in friday
night lights yeah he's a great actor
he's a great actor
yeah of course yeah oh no he's the yeah
yeah he's actually pretty damn wasn't he
was he in uh sling blade
is that tim no i don't know
oh damn that that's a that's an old
wraparound
he's pretty happy with his body huh but
look at him right there he's like yeah
no he's pissed
these people in the audience we're
booing him he jumps off stage and he's
like come straight to my face so he's
down to fight yeah because he was
performing and i guess he messed up some
of his lyrics and there was a section of
the crowd that started booing him for
that and it i guess it triggered him and
he's just wanted to confront them so he
jumped off the stage trying to
basically tell them say it to my face
tell me what you said are you talking
[ __ ] and you forgot the lyrics to his
main song i think he just fubbed some of
the lyrics it wasn't necessarily that
like you were dying and it sounded like
he was a little off like lyrically he's
like that i love that
so it's not that like i i having a
opinion on this
rocking chairs toward the west
though he waves it off at first like
[ __ ] off
looking then damn then yeah he's like
posting up that boy's dick first too bro
he's these
people like get back on stage
the crowd just keeps the bankies playing
yeah so people are saying do the show
you should just called him out on stage
but come on man so but also he's not a
conversation those fans would love
he i saw a few videos on this and he did
mess up on two really big songs
and i think honestly he's had issues
with alcohol before he said he quit
that's why he's so into intense and
working out because it's like that's how
it replaces his alcohol yeah so i think
this is this could be him
going back out
yeah he said it's because of filming too
many hours but
it looks like he was drunk but also how
about this ferris bear here but if
you're here to see tim mcgraw play his
hits in the fine city arena battery you
better hear the correct words
he wants some random moments of silence
or hearing made up lyrics no you want to
hear tim mcgraw do tim mcgraw thanks he
goes hey do you know how hard it is to
remember the words to every single song
granted they are your own songs but
still there's importance
there's some bands that have a
teleprompter you have to i can't
remember all my songs yeah
like you ever slipped up on [ __ ] on
stage sure like all this stuff
my buddy told the same joke twice
i told the joke one time and it just
didn't do well and i was like let me try
this again i'm gonna tell this joke with
a lot more [ __ ] pizzazz
i've done that before i missed
punchlines hey guys speaking of which
magoo oh goobies
it's only 20 minutes outside of
baltimore guys don't run you guys are
busting out the door everybody
there are enough tickets barely me and
chappelle are in bray friday and
saturday brea improv
dallas november 11th through the 13th
that's dallas texas yeah but this friday
saturday is brea all right jen back to
the event okay let me just download
these real quick this is a brand new one
by the way cincinnati outside cincinnati
sort of liberty township ohio that's
where i'll be october 22nd that funny
bone god damn look at that off the hook
that's a great one i can't wait
[ __ ] thursday to sunday did you do
sunday i don't do sundays i like the sun
that's the only place i'll ever do
sunday i don't do sunday anyway oh this
is my current event yeah this is i
thought this was really cute
all right here we go
guys i'm sorry that i've been
interrupting you this i feel like i've
been around you keep doing your dates
but sorry yeah no i've been interrupting
you oh you're good you're good i just
thought this was a cute thing this dad's
helping his daughter uh that's a
daughter
yeah awesome he's just making sure she
lands it but like the way he encourages
her yes
little badass yeah that was good
that's good
that's it
that's it
that's a really good camera
a person who makes a point says throw a
helmet on that young one dude i love her
like yeah oh beast right
her cakes are dope there's old school
blazers
they both got big i know
i just thought that was really cute
yeah i like
no that's not her oh i was like yeah
oh man she's young too yeah
that's dope that's so cute
that's what city is that dc that might
be
dc or moscow
i know right
like no philly
i don't know
[Music]
one major metropolitan city yeah you
know someone said come on throw it man
throw it throw it out
hey no no with skating you just got to
[ __ ] if you're a street skater you just
go you don't wear helmets no
look at this guy how are you if you're
doing supposed to be your entire life
making me sad my dad died
oh this is damn rob guys
all right maybe this video is not for
you
you sure you don't even kids don't wear
helmets i've seen little kids in hell
dude when i started skating i mean [ __ ]
how old i was we didn't wear no helmet
if you're doing like the half pipes and
all that stuff where you want to be
padded up and all that but like street
skating you kind of you just go man you
know
it's like i got scooters i'll never wear
helmet on my scooter yeah i don't
compare what'd you say your scooter you
got a scooter
what are you doing with a scooter right
now hey stevie had one oh like the uh
you're talking about that kind of stupid
yeah oh you're fine i'm gonna tell you
right now if i see you on a scooter and
a helmet i'm gonna punch you in the face
don't
hey do not compare your
stupid [ __ ] scooter to
a scooter safety first bud
like this you open your car door
you have your little belt dude you have
a little ding ding yeah
oh wow they get a basket up front these
are the most comfortable shoes well what
happened to them did a mountain lion
item i've been over using them oh my god
don't wear those but don't wear those
listen those look like you have no money
they're my on clouds they look like you
have
why would you wear those why don't you
wear the new ones they're brand new oh
got it can't find them though
got bigger legs
chappelle
dead lifting 500 pounds with no problemo
dude
bring that officer something did you do
it for just one but you could do it
tough i feel like you are on your way to
beating brendan shop i'm not on my way
to beat brenda well 600 pounds watch how
easy this is on the wall
look at this look at this
strong [ __ ] dude no problem
chappelle no problem you could do reps
with that
brennan you were right there i'll only
rest easy when you surpass brenda
that's right
now that's 500 pounds dude yeah
what do you think you max had i don't
know that was that was my 550 that was
my max right there it's not yet it was
no you just started you know how heavy
51 pounds is yeah you don't know
you don't know the game 20 pounds is a
lot that's what i'm saying even having
20 pounds yeah it's a world of
difference really yeah it's a huge
difference because i did 4.95 first and
then i was like oh yeah meatball you're
telling me but i was like i think i'm
gonna go for 500. because i go we'll
just put 500. yeah yeah
yeah he was like just put 500 when you
did 600 though it was like i could see
you really strained like your back was
both impossible i'll never do it again
but with you you just stood up with that
i feel like you but but you also realize
i think i'll go to my instagram story i
do 500.
what'd you say you have great form oh
thank you do i really yeah yeah you do
you have solid form without a belt well
you got a great phone got our boy mark
harley helping you out there i might
show up at the zoo oh i don't think you
have it on there b no it's not it's old
it's not on there uh i have the video
let me see that but he you you ready how
did you do it
oh wow covert [ __ ] posted how many
times can you do 500
15 what yeah have you seen this though
this mike catherine posted this i saw
chappelle liked it too oh yeah i love
this this dude is 680.
and he's not big that's what i'm saying
holy [ __ ] geez that's dangerous
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] insane he's a
small dude yeah he's [ __ ] crazy yeah
he's not here mike was that dude she's
ready she's so shredded so shredded
bigger now i've seen him in a little bit
he looks like you see
recent post chin what's up of him with
that 108 pound kettlebell you know what
he was doing with it all that [ __ ] i
don't know but he looks super shredded
god damn it and he's got the black flag
bars logo tattooed on his arm he's a
real one
yeah look at him look at him there you
go he's a great guy holy child right i
saw mike jogging the other day in
santa monica and he was looking i didn't
recognize him
god he's jack dude
he's such a good guy what is the
milligram of uh nicotine he does he does
like 40 or 60 milligrams yeah i can't
but he he used to be crazy into drugs
right yeah
holy [ __ ] he's in shape dude insanely in
shape yeah that's a big boy
there is a massive difference between
500 and 600 pounds obviously yeah
there's a massive difference between
five hundred and five ten
ten pounds is the world difference but
you're on the game
you have no clue what you're talking
about i don't know but you don't not at
our level
he was like once you get past 400 like
400 to 500 like years can't imagine yeah
it really depends on your threshold
because i got from the first time i left
i had squatted within less than a year i
got to 225 within like eight months and
then after that it took me another
like i'd say a year to get another 10 15
pounds
and brian told me he goes you could do
600. so you plateau and then like your
body is made to lift 500. now getting to
six is a whole world this is the
difference but also like 100 on your
deadlift is i mean insane
so
but but where did you start at that
maybe what did i start at you are
building i don't know strength i mean
you're a strong thinker what i started
with right i mean he is
if there's anybody who i've seen who
looks like they naturally look very
built for to lift heavy things you're
one of those guys oh i thank you but you
are
oh that's right
his thing would with his bill to be
squat
not deadlift or bench why is that just
different body type just different
squats i got them thighs yeah now what
do you do
is touch you have to be careful with
squat right you mean you got weight on
your back and all that it's not
shut the [ __ ] up
please leave you i don't know dude
500 is not safe either
i feel i feel uh just hit the shower no
i like it the way he said that he goes
now squad
him telling you 600
he's not in there he told me he's trying
to he has no
yeah i think it is i think you should
add 30 pounds and see what happens we're
not doing that
at least i'm not talking to you
listen to me right now dude
dude let me tell you
dude let us
let us let us do that please man
you're bullying us you know you know
what i want you to do is max out on
deadlift whatever [ __ ] training you
have and then add 100 pounds on the next
day just so you can learn a little bit
about what we do
when he goes hey hey brian your max is
225 go cool today throw on 325 and let
me know how it goes for you
and then you just kind of have a dip
your toe in the pool dip your toe a
little bit mm-hmm are you talking about
four or five hundred six hundred pounds
don't give me my max at 225 first of all
that's what it is you say your max is
250 right i don't know oh for deadlift
wait i thought you told me
did you [ __ ] lie to me yeah he lied
to you no i no he does the trap bar yeah
which we don't count did you know the
only trap party oh he does that like uh
what is it the the the [ __ ]
bar hex bar yeah yeah that that that for
guys like us i thought that was like a
legitimate though when we want to go
super heavy no one counts it it doesn't
matter how much you do on it you're not
like when you bench on a smith press
we don't count it
because it's not the same is it facts
you know what i'm saying it really is
it's like you like that
you like that beyond burger right yeah
it's not a [ __ ] burger is it well
it's like leg press it's like he does a
hack he does that that's a hex squat
that's not a real squat is it is it
though that's a lot of weight it doesn't
matter
if you can do a thousand pounds like no
one it's better for your back though ah
it's not though if you know how to do it
right you know what i'm saying like
nobody's gonna go like oh you see that
guy yeah heck squad a thousand yeah we
don't care
it's like you're you're right you're
right you're right it's your beyond
burgers yeah eyebrows with brandon
you're right i remember i was right when
we were at a gym and there was a guy i'm
just gonna be a real general and there
was a guy and uh
you know i knew brennan could deadlift a
lot and this guy was
he had 450 pounds in the bar
and he had a he had chains on his
chains on on the sides of it and he also
had a
mouthpiece he had a mouthpiece which is
so intense the way this guy had a
mouthpiece and he had those you know
what else bothers me and
is the guys that lift with uh deadlift
shoes on
they have no idea drives me nuts yeah
well that's kind of like wait wait wait
wait
wait what is the deadlift you have dead
lift shoes i do not vlog oh wow this is
i can't hate on people who wait whatever
is that like a special title
is super solid so when you push it's not
like you're pushing into your shoe it's
not cushiony oh it's not yeah so it
helps to push up a lot of people wear
like that's why you see jordan ones or
like cons well people were well i like
it like i like the flat as possible also
annoys me what do you say uh mark harley
did that though yeah well you were the
one yeah i meant mark you're here now
that bothers me
what are you doing well hey hold on yeah
put your shoes on they're engaging their
feet no i know listen
nobody cares put your shoes on but
you're engaging but also when you come
with those like velcro straps and the
heels all flat like that it's not that
serious is it
are you getting paid to do this
does anybody can make money but
put dude but put your shoes on but
i know some people were trying to talk
about
for lifting in the for dead lifting in
those ones does it matter i go what does
it [ __ ] matter it doesn't matter
safety
doesn't matter but i mean let me tell
you something insurance problem i could
lift an air max 90s with a giant bubble
out the back doesn't matter okay
okay
put mark
put shoes on
but he just wants to feel the ground and
if you show up again in dead lifting
shoes i'm not lifting with you who mark
harley yep oh he has those he has those
boots hey
if you show up in dead lifting shoes
again
i'm never lifting with you he looks he's
looking thicker
sure he's a big boy hey big boy and his
hair is looking fluffed up yeah fluffy
yeah he did 500 for 10 yesterday well
mark mark the man lion
harley is looking
rather rather puffy
so congratulations he did do 509 times
10
he was nine he did no he got it he put
it on his instagram
he said right there
oh was nine sorry oh no that was 495. no
shoes but he does
oh because i put on the two and a half
socks
mark put your shoes on oof that's a lot
of weight
oh that's a lot of weight
yeah
all natty baby
he's using straps i'd like it well
documented that i didn't use any straps
when i did it
i used lasso hat on they're shaming nike
uh what was i wearing yesterday those
like those dunks those high dumps yep
yeah put your shoes on
put shoes on come on dude like this hey
but it's not that serious you know what
i'm saying are you ready we're not the
world's stronger man contest you know
what i'm saying but you're at zoo
culture doesn't matter put your shoes on
what is what does uh bradley martin wear
normal shoes yeah
yeah
because it's not that serious is it
don't wear those shoes
with a high heel don't wear those don't
wear this no oh and it also bothers me
when they wrap their knees
really when they what those guys oh the
knee sleeves
what about them what about chalk
chalk makes sense yeah
it's right there i don't have to plant
it ahead of time don't wrap your knees
don't have your knees what do you wrap
your knees for nothing you know yeah we
don't wear we don't wear the belt
can i see this what about when you wear
the tape on your arms nope but don't do
that
then maybe it's not for you you know
i've seen people wear the tape and i'm
not sure what that's doing dude if
you're sponsored by metrix or [ __ ]
celtec do it
but if you're just doing it yeah don't
do that not making any money online i
used to work out at the venice barbell
club guys get taped up it went out of
business but they would tape up they'd
wrap their knees and i was like
you know
why do they why do they do that no i
like to play tennis and i pay attention
and i see guys that come in and they
have
seven rackets then they walk in with a
case seven rackets and they're [ __ ]
terrible it just takes one racquet
that's right
when i would box and i would get in
there spar a little bit and there'd be
guys in there and they would show up
with boxing shoes and a bag full of all
their stuff all the gear and but it was
legit boxers though no no these are just
guys and then you i
those guys were the guys that were
they were so bad
well it's like this morning i was riding
my bike there's some guy on the trail
and the full get up yeah he says what
what the [ __ ]
yeah i love i like because
i'm talking the same way sir are you
sponsored by the postal service
no do you ride with lance armstrong you
receive no dollars why are you dressed
like that brandon and i brad and i are
on it it's probably comfortable brandon
it's not
austin love going there great gym
and you just see dudes there with their
shirt off they can't wait it's their
time it's they can't
wait to talk
but i look at brennan one time and i was
like watching him and he's doing i mean
he's it's his thing
working out is his sport you understand
they got a shirt off
they're a couple guys that's their sport
that's what they do they're not getting
paid for it and they're not but it's
theirs it's their time to shine and
they're making they're like it's an
investment it's an investment so they're
just showing you they're a lot more
intense and i said to brett and i go
i said
you ever uh done that he said he goes
what's that i can already tell because
he's staring i go happy the guy was body
dumb dog you never worked out with your
shirt off because not one time in my
life
here's the other thing he said there's a
lot of guys to do this thing and this
one guy i know and he trains a lot and i
said how would you do against him and he
we're walking or walking and he and as i
i go how do you think i would do
and
it was so us
it was so such an affront i just your
face goes right here your face goes we
go you go and just like this you go i
imagine pretty well brian because i get
paid to fight i got paid for a long time
he's never made one dollar fighting and
never had a profile so i would imagine
pretty well as we're walking in my face
i didn't know you that well i was like
oh oh jesus you know what's weird is
like uh you know
playing football see you like we'd work
out hard each time middle of summer yeah
not one guy would take the shirt off
because you get eaten alive dude
eating even alive yeah if you came in
there with like special shoes and like
knee braces
you get eaten a lot housing and we were
high level football players that would
make sense and you still and not and you
could you couldn't do it most you still
ain't making it in the nfl no no you
still ain't making it on a team and as
great as you are in college you still
ain't
yeah
and that's why i understand why you get
upset when people talk about their high
school football days and how they
were going to go really anything because
you're telling me my friend was supposed
to play in the nba nfl it wasn't
it wasn't
what are you well i watched this hard
knockout
i'm like these guys are so good they're
good they're so good not a ch they're
not even smelling it and they're doing
they're they just miss and they're
making tackles and they're actually yeah
they're good in games in pre-season
games and still you just couldn't find
the whole not smelling it you couldn't
find the whole time or the ball should
bounce their way or the defense lined up
so that's enough he gets two plays but
the dm is double covering him so he
didn't get a shine and gets cut yeah and
you're a defensive end and you're 235
you're not 240 when these guys go i was
playing that felt like anyway you're
telling me you'd even go to training
camp no come on
these are people that only played in
high school that are talking this [ __ ]
some friends i ran a four or five some
of bryce
in high school i've heard that from
500 people in my life i've said it
before yeah no you said 40. that's it
she's even more outrageous hey listen i
know i didn't but that's what the coach
said i know and your coach is liar i
know he was i bet you were fast
yeah and that's what brenda said too
maybe no
maybe four six yeah i would give myself
a four zero four seven that's very fast
in high school that's blazing
and i was in saccone's you know shoes
but it was yeah it was weird that i mean
it was like the talk of the town people
still bring it up to me all the time i
go i don't know 40. yeah and i go no i
didn't do that the whole town was fooled
huh
yeah no you might it sounds like your
town's full of buttons people were
coming up to me right after like i
remember because it was in p.e they
wanted me to try out for the football
team but i was cheering at the time or
whatever and uh the coach was like can
you run a 40 and i didn't know what a 40
was or whatever and then uh he was like
running 40 yard dash
i still didn't know make sense so he
uh he's gonna run from here to here and
then i was like i can't just run by
myself you got to give me something to
like run against me a rabbit so he he
put me up against like another faster
dude and then uh like i just ran to 40
and then he was like damn it was a 4-3
and i was like don't know what that
means but everyone was like what the
[ __ ] had you ever run before had you
ever had any
ram before had you had any sprinting did
you have anything else
yeah oh okay of course he's running he
had no track you did none of that yeah
he wasn't
he wasn't locked in a basement
the guys that are running for four or
fives for yeah in the nfl and
they actually run with good form well he
was the one that makes it broken down to
me he was
he was like you know what chappelle you
did not run a 4-3 i said i did he goes
he goes you didn't run 4-3 and i said i
was like bring it that's what the coach
showed me whatever he goes he goes yeah
yeah he goes i don't think you're not
fast you're probably fast but you're not
a 4-3 faster yeah and then he pulls out
his phone i said
and pulls up before three and i saw the
guy running i go oh yeah i did it was
like crazy
yeah
i was like there's no really good
performance and like that insane amount
of speed i was like oh there's no way
you see an actual four three like four
two like holy pull up before three chin
four three run bring it out first john
runs the 40-yard dash then you did like
four two eight
someone did it in 4-2
what did metcalf ride 40-yard dash yeah
yeah there is chris johnson 40. there's
just [ __ ] no way
four two two well this is oh my god this
is blazing fess
well there's tyree kill who else ran a
four three these are all four threes
there's no way in hell i did that i
didn't look like that
no i didn't feel that no wait that's
2007 2009 those all ran fourth those
were four twos
this is four two eights
look at these [ __ ] yeah
now
look how big his [ __ ] legs are
god damn and now and so that he's at the
top now this is a 4-2-7 good one's a
beast
oh my god 4-2-7 what
i think he was on the track to him as
well so wait but they use a different
they use a different clock right it's
it's electricity but they're also what
look at their test so as soon as he
moves it's all it's it's it's not but
there is by hand there's some guys down
by hand but it's all calculated by
machine learning okay you know these are
actual four two six look at this
technique like that they run really
correctly so to get to get the accuracy
of it they use a machine four two four
jesus christ
what against christ
effortlessly faces relax
look how fast his legs move
yeah big dead i know that runs like that
well he's got a dick on him because it
looks big even when he's running when
you're running everything clams up
everything tightens up yeah what else
you got gin
all right um
so we talked about this on below the
belt chuckled we had no we only heard
that he had a domestic violence
arrest right
we didn't have any details but it turns
out this is what chuck's saying
if anyone wants to read it or you only
read it it's important okay i was a
victim of the incident last night at our
high family home
as detailed the case will reveal the
deputies informed me that my wife would
be arrested as did not as i did not
respond to her assault while i sustained
bruising and lacerations i volunteered
to go in her place
this was one of the many times i have
tried to shield a family mental health
issue
from the public purview it has become
painfully apparent that this cannot
continue as our private life has now
reached a public breaking point please
respect our privacy as i helped navigate
our family through this difficult time
tough yeah and i know he and his wife a
little bit just a little bit just a
little bit and i mean he's supposed to
be on food truck uh next tuesday i i
mean honestly when i read the report too
it seems like it is an issue with his
wife this is just my point of view
i'll still have them and unless you give
me something hard yeah they've been
together for a long time i don't know if
showtime's gonna allow i hope i
definitely i like chuck chuck i've known
chuck for a long time
i hope i hope the best for both of them
me too
they've been together a long time i'm
sure there's a lot of love there i don't
know um from what i read
if i remember correctly something like
the police said that he did say
he doesn't want her to go to jail right
so he'll go to jail in place for her
that's cool yeah yeah that's what it's
he said yeah statement she she may have
some issues and that's [ __ ] tough man
yeah i hope they work it out man me too
yeah i just never
it's tough did it not yeah
yeah it's tough and you know obviously
you never know what's going to happen
also food truck that yeah we should
probably cancel on chuck i'm like why no
we don't know the facts no what happened
and i was like
i've been around this girl you know
she's
she's a boss man like she's a tough
tough girl so it's like i need more
facts before i kick him off that 100
i support it you know that like i
support chuck they've been married
they've made this wait till all the
information comes out first and then
make a big accomplishment they've made
them yeah but i'm not going to write the
guy up no yeah wait til everything comes
they made the marriage last a long time
how about that the fact that they've
been together a long time they raised
kids it's really [ __ ] hard who knows
what they're going through who knows
what she's going through you know we see
more details when you hang the guy out
the dress and he's the one with the
lacerations yeah yeah sure but he went
to jail for her so there's love someone
hasn't been arrested so he's probably
going to he talked about mental health
issues people can have that mm-hmm
so
that's it there you go hi kids friday
saturday break up baby one of our
favorite clubs chappelle's favorite club
yep this friday saturday is brea then
november 11th to the 13th dallas texas
addison improv get your tickets texas
october 30th calabasas fight command
with a very special guest and also
november 6 calabasas fight companion
again very special guest and it's a
double header that's the canelo caleb
plant and also ufc 269 i think well
let's get that picture off because i
look like i have a gut in that now i'm
going to be in uh let's go to 15 16.
this weekend timonium i'm at mcgoobie's
joke house then i got uh then i got
liberty's township ohio uh that's
basically cincinnati the funny bone
october
23rd and then i've got by the way ahmed
brea the fourth and the fifth of
november fourth and the fifth and then
we got five companion november sixth
uh
and uh and then november 11 12 13 14 i'm
at off the hook comedy club tickets are
on sale and already selling off the
comedy club in naples florida uh
chappelle yeah october 28th through the
30th i'll be in washington dc at the dc
dog what happened sorry bro you grabbed
my thigh
it didn't [ __ ] yeah
dc get your ticket
all right
bro touching my [ __ ] legs mississippi
november 17th uh tacoma comedy club
november 18th spokane comedy club uh
december 1st san jose improv yeah dog
all right guys love you see you bye